fought for our land for our people and
for what we thought was right but then
we heard the loud voices of support from
the lgbtq community all over the world
these were the voices of the Brave and
proud who did not stay silent when we
were in need their support opened our
eyes they made us realize that there is
a more important battle to fight a
battle for equality and the right to
love they made us realize that it is
okay to be gay we've used to suppress
now we express our fabulous Pride
there's nothing to hide we had time to
reflect and we finally understood that
while we were trying to fight the Jews
we were actually fighting ourselves and
our inner desires but from now on there
will be no more hiding no more shame and
no more fear que people around the world
made us realize who our true enemy is
spoiler alert it isn't Israel but
intolerance so today we fight a
different battle a battle for the right
to love the immense support of the queer
for Palestine movement has opened a new
perspective for Hamas and taught them
that they had to do a
rebranding from now on they called
themselves ham ass embracing their new
journey of acceptance and love for buts
and fresh meat in a world craving change
sometimes the most unexpected voices
lead the way witness the story of
Courage transformation and Unity coming
soon Hamas a new Revolution a story of
change a story of Hope
some people have turkey on Thanksgiving
some people have ham ass I'm Dave Ruben
this is the Ruben report it's November
22nd 2023 it's Thanksgiving tomorrow I
hope you will be with friends and family
eating some great food drinking some
good wine and just enjoying yourself and
being appreciative for whatever you got
we're going to do a slightly abbreviated
show today it's going to be a Ruben
report Community Q&A at Ruben report.
locals.com and uh a couple stories up
top just sort of General people going
crazy about the stuff that they usually
go crazy about and of course that will
involve some politicians and mainstream
media people and everything else so
let's just Dive Right to it so that I
can get out there and smoke this turkey
because it's going to be like a 12-h
hour operation for me uh let's start
with Morning Joe this is Joe Scarboro
over on the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC he's freaking out because
the polls are looking good for Trump and
Trump's a mean orange man he's not a
normal candidate he is running to end
American democracies as we know it he's
an authoritarian who a court uh in in
Colorado two days ago ruled that that he
led an Insurrection against the United
States government he's charged with
leading schemes to help overthrow the
United States government so so if they
want to frame it uh that way that's fine
if Donald Trump a candidate who supports
a new form of government here that's
authoritarian it's really that simple
and by the way Reverend Allen people go
oh you can't compare him to past Nazi
leaders you can't compare him to this
past Nazi leader or that past fascist
leader because he hasn't done that well
what hasn't he done he hasn't done the
things that the American judicial system
did not allow him to do last time but
may very well allow him to do this time
and if he is voted into office then a
lot of these people that are talking
about literal or figurative or whatever
the hell they're saying you're going to
look like idiots uh because he will do
he will get away with he will imprison
he will execute whoever he's allowed to
imprison execute uh uh a drive from the
country ju just look at his past Joe Joe
take a chill pill man first off you're
not allowed to just randomly imprison
and execute people so everything you're
saying is completely he will imprison
and execute everyone that he's allowed
to imprison and execute well you can't
just imprison and execute people for no
reason I know you guys would like to
imprison him for several sort of farsal
reasons and you would love to execute
him right it was who was it Congressman
Dan Goldman who just two or three days
ago congressman from New York who said
that we have to
eliminate uh president Trump he said
that on your network by the way I didn't
hear you uh make any comments about him
um but it's all you guys get it it's all
just endless hysteria with these people
all they have nothing that they can sell
Biden on really although we'll get to
their comments on him in just a second
so it's just endless hysteria oh my God
Trump's starting to pull well there's
nothing cool about the Democrats anymore
the counter culture thing and the Trump
thing obviously is picking up some kind
of steam where it just feels like it's
moving a little
bit so he must be a fascist and he must
be a Nazi and everything else even
though it was you guys that were
colluding between the government and
Tech to silence him by the way there was
no Insurrection there was no plan to
take over the government and every it's
all but speaking of B the woman that
he's sitting next to on that show it
blows my mind every time we see one of
these clips do you know that Joe Joe
Scaro is married to that woman they're
not just co-hosts they're also doing it
probably not that not well though I feel
like they don't do it well but they
probably occasionally do it her name's M
MAA brzinsky and uh she's freaking out
because people have started to notice
that something's not right with Joe
Biden and she just she can't take it she
can't take you people noticing what's
happening he's brought the world
together and the thing is this is the
most I'm going to lose it literally I'm
going to lose it like they bring up his
age you bring up his age he's 80 years
old he makes jokes about his age and yet
he's working on every level foreign and
domestically and then you're you're are
you making the argument is one making
the argument that oh he's 80 therefore a
voter is going to vote for Donald Trump
like that's the choice by the way Donald
Trump is 77 and and doesn't make any
sense even when he was in office he had
executive time where he just sat off the
the room in in theal office and he would
watch cable news Around the Clock where
Biden is working around the clock on
foreign policy first off put aside
anything that they just said right there
what is that clown car of people in
those boxes that gay cowboy and that
crazy social justice Warrior the two
other people who look like they're going
to puke what is going on over there it
should be studied it really should uh ma
m nobody is upset that the guy is 80 or
81 although as I brought up on the show
yesterday I don't know anyone I
literally do not know one person and I
ask these three guys does anyone in this
room know one person that's 81 still
working a full-time job obviously such
people exist but I don't know any they
don't know any Joe Biden is obviously
not capable of doing the job but don't
and by the way it's not purely because
of his age right it's the cognitive
stuff that is coming along with his age
because you could be 81 and super fit
and super aware and all of those those
things but we know that he is not do we
have some sort of compilation video of
that kind of thing my God we do I uh
um
anyway the best way to get something
done if you if it holds near and dear to
you that you uh um like to be able
to anyway from from uh uh Char excuse me
from Charlotte one on another line going
from in Florida down to Tampa of Putin's
CL
talk
yeah and and and Joan Shen
gang
shanga 50, 159,000 billion dollars L
America is a nation that can be defined
in a single word I was foot him foot
the idea that
um Los Angeles and uh and uh um uh um
what am I doing here for two reasons one
to we haven't been able to communicate
it in a way that is uh
um make me say another way but the
nature not
a solid
meeting with um with
uh the uh they make a very good point
here's the
deal
M come on what are you doing what are
you doing anyway here's Joe Biden acting
like a creep and by the way I like kids
Better Than
People I wish I could stay and watch
Wonka with you but I'm not going to get
to do that does he know that kids are a
type of people like I like kids Better
Than People and do not let your kids
watch willly Wonka or anything else with
Joe Biden anyway they're running cover
for him we all know they're running
cover for for him it's just ridiculous
cringe Jean Pierre over at the White
House diversity hire cringe Jean Pier
she will put Joe Biden against anybody
because he's strong and vital
I would put the president's stamina
president's wisdom ability to get this
done on behalf of of uh the American
people against anyone anyone on any day
of the week it's just meaningless
dribble you get it so before we roll
into Thanksgiving and I get to the
community Q&A I thought we can't just
show the nonsense right the nonsense of
course of MSNBC the nonsense of a of a
crumbling Joe Biden the obfuscation by
his ridiculous press secretary how about
somebody saying saying something a lot
of people are saying maybe Plan B is
Gavin Nome you are going to sit across
from Gavin Nome a week from this
Thursday uh with the big debate against
Shan Hannity I know in your head you
would like to be the nominee on the
Republican side Gavin Nome you know he
wants to be the Democrat is this a
preview of
2024 in your dream sequence look he is
he he is running a sh Shadow campaign
even people in his own party are saying
that uh a lot of Democrats want to move
Biden out uh and so you know you could
have Harish you could have new you could
have a lot of different people but I
think it's important that Republican
voters uh get get uh get the sense that
that we may not be running against Biden
I think it's worth noting and the reason
I wanted to do all that before
Thanksgiving is because we are all going
to sit down at a table tomorrow with
family and friends and and newcomers and
everything else and politics you know it
just sits there these days it's just
there whether you think it's there or
not everything has become political
that's one of the problems in our
society and you're going to sit there
with people that are going to tell you
Joe Biden's just fine they're going to
tell you the Democrats are great they're
going to all of the nonsense and you
should just be able to cleanly talk to
people and tell them the truth and
bantis is consistently good at that and
you should be able to tell your
relatives and the other people sitting
across the table from you do you really
think it's Joe Biden do you really think
he's running the show right now do you
really think he has the stamina to be
president and if if you don't think that
like do you want Camala Harris to be
president or do you want Gavin Newsome
to be president and what is it that you
really think is so evil about
Republicans do you really think like Joe
Scarboro that Donald Trump is a fascist
and a racist and a Nazi and he forgot to
do all of that stuff the first time
around do you really think that all the
awful things they say about Ronda santz
are true and of the state Florida and
all that like whether you want to or not
cuz I know most people especially now
because politics has gotten so crazy
people want to not be involved in
politics when it comes to to sitting
down with family and I'm I am that way
too I absolutely have that in me too but
if we can't work these things out with
the very people that you break bread
with on the day that you're supposed to
be thankful for all of our freedoms then
in some ways we've kind of lost the game
already so uh let's leave it at that let
me get to a Ruben report Community Q and
a Mary says do you think it would at all
be helpful to take the Federalist Papers
dumb the language down to approximately
a sixth to eighth grade level and run
them as paid advertisements in
newspapers today oo I love that idea yes
I do actually I think you could take the
Federalist Papers explain to people why
states rights are important I mean I
talk about this all the time of course
and why local government is way more
important than the federal government
and we we left England to avoid the king
who had autonomous control over
everybody and that we broke down this
beautiful Federalist system so that
local control would have far more uh to
do with your life than the federal
government and that we've unfortunately
in modern times just reversed that so
that we we just Outsource so much of the
control of our life to the president
which is completely the reverse of what
we were trying to do 250 plus years ago
that would be great I think putting
maybe you know it's funny you mentioned
newspapers like I don't know if the
newspapers will get the point across to
enough people but fig some campaign to
really have people understand what the
Constitution is all about what the
Declaration of of Independence is all
about these are not very long documents
to read by the way what the Bill of
Rights are all about like could we do
some sort of renewal related to that
that would that would be uh pretty good
uh crafty says Dave will you take your
boys somewhere to see the Snows sled now
that they can enjoy it a bit yes
absolutely so David is really big on
this his one thing with Florida right
now is that we don't really get Seasons
right we had one day like three weeks
ago where we could put hoodies on but
we're obviously not getting snow down
here he grew up in Maryland I grew up in
New York so we're used to you know a
normal snowy winter and all that uh so
now that the boys are more than one we
can start traveling a bit more so my
guess is probably maybe next Christmas
time we can do something that will get
us to a colder atmosphere and uh yeah I
do want them to experience that because
as much as I love Florida and I love the
heat now and I love sweating I don't
mind it in the summer and all all the
reasons that I'm always telling you I
love it down here there's something
about seasons and and yeah they should
experience that of course uh Olaf says
have you ever thought about doing uh
Standalone in-depth shows on a single
topic like John stasel has done if so
what topic comes first to mind you know
it's a great idea we've kicked around
some stuff like this what stasel does
and you guys know John stasel he was on
2020 for decades I actually have believe
it or not I have an Emmy because John
stasel once gave me an Emmy of his he's
won something like 20 Emmys over the
years and uh his wife is a leftist or at
least was a leftist and in all the years
that he's been a well-known libertarian
he could never get her to watch an
interview with Thomas soul but for some
reason because she likes me she watched
my interview with Thomas soul and then
she kind of was like into the ideas so
one day a box just showed up at my house
and it was an Emmy from John stasel with
a little note thank you for opening my
wife's eyes up to the ideas of Thomas
Soul so that's pretty cool but what he
does he does more like sort of like mini
docks on you know here's what's going on
at our universities or here's what's
happening at our food processing plants
or things of that nature we've thought
about doing some things like that and uh
stay tuned for the year 2024 uh
Stephanie says why is Thanksgiving your
favorite holiday yeah I mentioned that
Thanksgiving was my favorite holiday a
couple weeks ago I would say first off I
just love especially these days like
just freaking giving thanks for
everything you know like it all I know
it all feels crazy and they want you to
believe this place is racist and
whatever but all of us in the United
States of America in 2023 we have so
much to be thankful for and as I always
say maybe it is tenuous that this thing
will hold on and in which case when
we're on the other side of it we're
going to be pretty freaking pissed that
we didn't be more thankful for it and do
more to stop the craziness um but this
country has given us all so much and the
story of all of our families wherever
they came from and and that it's it's so
baked in to a day where all of us
doesn't matter what color you are what
religion you are what sexuality you are
any of that nonsense like if you can't
take a
minute just say it's pretty good today
have some food and look around that
table and be like all right kind of like
some of these people at least like you
got a bigger problem than whatever you
think the problem with America is I
would also say I would put at a close
onea on my favorite holiday list uh I do
love Passover you know Passover of
course is uh the story of the Hebrews
leaving Egypt and you're not going to
believe where they went this is
thousands of years ago they went to the
promised land we now know that as Israel
uh but it's really the story of freedom
and how every generation must fight for
Freedom that oppression comes and it
always looks a little bit different but
it has the same markers and telling that
story every year I think it's actually
one of the thing things that's baked
into the code as to why Jews end up
sticking around despite a lot of bad
guys trying to take them out
Alex says what is stopping us
politicians from speaking like Javier
Malay uh well first off um well we have
a Donald Trump right so there's one guy
that is doing something a little bit
more like that it will be very very
interesting to see if Malay continues to
speak the way he has spoken before you
know he was a TV guy he was a former
soccer player he's got the crazy hair
like can he bring all of those pieces
and not be crushed as the globalists and
and the the entire sort of WF thing as
they they really will start focusing on
Argentina right because they're not
going to want Argentina to be a success
for story it's not a great thing for
them if this libertarian comes in hacks
away at all the agencies he already got
rid of their like feminist diversity
department and he's going to get rid of
the education department and all of
these things or at least that's what he
says he's going to do it will not be a
good example if he can get rid of all of
that if he can fix up what's going on
with them financially fire a lot of the
Civil employees and then have a a
flourishing economy that will not be
good for these people so I suspect
they're going to try to do some weird
things with h with Argentina over the
next year or so uh but yes more plain
speaking or somewhat silly overthe toop
open collar just let it fly it would
probably be good in politics Tay says I
know you're a big tequila guy how's that
going by the way uh but what are some of
your non uh some of your favorite
non-alcoholic drinks coffee tea soda Etc
uh so first off our tequila which I'm
not allowed to we the is in trademark
process right now so I can't tell you
the name uh but it is being uh it is set
aside it is in Mexico it is in a barrel
well it's probably in a couple barrels I
guess I forget how many we ordered at
the beginning how many cases um but
we're going to test it out we've tried a
few things stay tuned on that as for
non-alcoholic drinks I mostly drink
water well I coffee in the morning I
have my tequila when I can and I'm a
water guy but I have got into I just
happened to have one next to me right
now they are not a sponsor of the show
this spin drift stuff I I am freaking
addicted to this I drink like two or
threes a two or three two or three of
these a day it's got four or five
calories depending on the flavor just a
tad bit of fruit juice but there's no
sugar there's no high fructose corn
syrup or any of that stuff
and that's pretty
good that's pretty good that just
reminded me of the scene inside fell
when Kramer when he takes the drinks the
beer then he smokes the cigarettes and
uh yeah that's uh that's it though um
let's see we can save America 2024 good
name says if we set aside Trump and Des
santis who would be first second and
third for president wow if you got rid
of the big two right now I mean well
look we I mean if just by conventional
how it is well all you've got left now
at least running are VCA and Nikki right
Jim Scott's out every did the eyebrow
guy we he he dropped everybody's out
everybody's out who would I like to see
like if you if you just if Trump into
senst just went on a honeymoon to
together tomorrow like who would I
really like to see like doing it and
Elon would be interesting he wasn't born
in the United States so we'd have a
problem there but like somebody that has
consistently shown they are fighting the
right fights would be good someone who
was a bit younger would be good somebody
with some business experience perhaps
would be good um give me someone who's
who's an American that would represent
that like an industry leader that Dave
Dave pornoy that would be an interesting
one it would be free pizza for everybody
give me give me somebody else who we got
who do we got maybe
uh Tucker Jamie Diamond I'm I'm gonna do
a little thinking on this one I will get
back to you on this uh lady broad says
Dave to date who are your top three
interviews well I always tell people the
Thomas Soul one just if you watch that
first minute with him is the only time
I've ever been nervous interviewing
anyone ever I kid you not I never get
nervous if I speak in front of 10,000
people I I don't get nervous when I do
interviews or any of that but I was
actually there was something about that
day and being with this guy who I knew
was a legend and all of it maybe it was
a little bit about his age I I don't
know but you can hear it in my voice I'm
a little like choked up at the beginning
of it and he was just absolutely
wonderful and I would say that one
because so many people come up to me now
and they're like Dave I never heard of
this guy like young younger Generations
never heard of the legendary Economist
Thomas soul and his story his personal
story of going from communist to a
capitalist and every and just the way he
speaks and everything else like the fact
that I've been a little bit of that
story to to get his ideas out there is
pretty freaking awesome so I would say
that one you know any of the times I sat
down with Jordan particularly The Early
times when we didn't really know each
other and we were kind of doing that
dance together and what I felt was like
oh here's this guy he's like he's like
this modern Prophet saying saying so
many profoundly deep things and if I can
just kind of funnel them into something
that's a little more understandable for
people maybe that would be my job or my
usefulness here and I think I've done
that fairly well uh and then of course
that our that our friendship and our the
way we've worked together over the years
has really expanded and continues to
expand is a beautiful thing let me try
to think of one that's like a little
more outside of that you know I sat down
with um Richard Lewis the comedian who's
one of my favorite stand-up comics of
all time he came to the house when we
were in LA and uh and he was just such a
sweet nice guy and he was super funny
and just you know it's all off the cuff
with him and everything else and you
know he's known as a big germaphobe they
actually make some jokes about it he's
in kir Your Enthusiasm with Larry David
and they have some back and forth jokes
about being germaphobes and it's true
that he is so he doesn't like to shake
people's hands he always does sort of a
fist bump like that but at the end of
the interview I was walking him out of
the house and I walk him to the front
gate uh and I said I said Richard I just
I just want to thank you like this was
such a thrill for me I'm such a fan and
you know I remember watching your first
young comedian special he was on a a
young comedian special a Rodney
Dangerfield young comedian special on
HBO I think around 1986 with Jerry
Seinfeld it was both of their first TV
debuts if I'm not mistaken I telling him
all this stuff and he he put his hand on
my face like this he just like his like
soft hand he put on my face like this
and he's like thank you you're you're
really great you're really great and I
was just like what a nice little moment
what a nice little moment uh let's see
um Lauren says did you have a favorite
toy and do you still have it well my
easy answer would be Soundwave that I
have over here we we had Soundwave but
we busted him out on the show the other
day Soundwave of course Decepticon
Transformer got him for my birthday I
think in 1985 so I was 9 years old uh I
remember a few days before my birthday
going to Toys R Us and they were
literally opening up the crates in front
of the Transformers aisle and like
begging my parents could we just buy my
birthdays next week I don't have to open
it yet you just hide it from me blah and
they did and they hid it from me and I
didn't see till my birthday but I
remember opening them up that morning um
what else on on the toy department you
know I've still got I don't know if this
quite counts as toy but I still got my
original apit Nintendo Entertainment
System upstairs and it still works you
got to blow in there and I years ago it
wasn't working at all and I watched a
YouTube video and I took it apart and I
fiddled with all the widgets and I got I
got like a little uh what do you call it
a little blower little you have one of
those things a little air blower and I
had to you know get all the dust out of
there and that thing's still humming so
there you go Harrison says uh what are
your thoughts strong and weak positions
on the top three candidates all right so
top three candidates uh we got obviously
Trump to santis and should we say Vicky
uh Vicky Nikki we can combine Nikki and
rebec into Vicki um all right I'll try
to do them all real quick so Trump
what's the strongest point he's Trump he
is a force of nature there is nothing
like him the the the reactions he causes
both ways that is his strength it's an
unbelievably um it's it's like
ubiquitous it's it's everywhere and
everything all the time with Trump that
is absolutely his
strength I would also and then I guess
his weak you could probably argue that's
his weakness too but I would say his
weakness is his inability to control
some of his impulses so so many of the
people who have been part of what he has
done have turned on him or he turns on
them and ultimately over time one of one
of my biggest fears with him will be
that if he became president again that
he will just have no one good working
for him and we will just have traitors
on the inside and it will just be four
disastrous years that would be him Dan
santis the
strength the strength is the clarity and
the operational success right I don't
know that there's ever been a politician
in our time that has just said I am
going to do these things he has done
these things and he's clear about it he
picks the right fights and he
accomplishes all of the all of the
things he sets out to do sets out to do
the weakness I suppose and people ask me
this like what is the weak the weakness
I guess maybe I'll do it in two ways
with him one would be he's not the most
off-the-cuff thing so the thing that
people love about Trump the santis
doesn't really have that so at debates
it's just like he's giving you standard
stuff he's giving you red meat stuff he
doesn't you don't walk out of a debate
going oh my God I'm so moved by any of
that um and I guess you can make an
argument and if if the polls mean
anything I guess you can make an
argument that as a campaigner it has not
translated that might be more to do with
Trump's strength which is just the the
sheer sort of volume of Trump that would
sort of have made it impossible for
anybody Nikki the strength the strength
with Nikki I think the strength with her
seems to be just like there's like a she
has sort of like an inner strength
something like that like she really
seems to know ah is that really right
with her trying to think for a second
what is the strength with
her you know what the strength with her
is she was a damn good governor in South
Carolina nobody gives her any any crap
for that she did a lot of good there
turned it into a really strong State and
she was an except here's a better one
she was an exceptionally good uh US
ambassador at the UN she the UN is one
of the most rat-infested corrupt
organizations in the history of humanity
and she went in there under the Trump
Administration and fought for American
values every single day and did it with
Grace and dignity and all that so I
would say that is her strength her
strength is that I don't think she would
fear going into meetings with XI
jingping or going into meetings with Kim
Jong-un or any else and and operating
from a place of weakness I think that is
where she probably shines her
weakness her weakness I suppose
is like a blanket weakness with her I'm
trying to think like there there's
something that feels too old school
about the campaign or something like
there's just no like magic to it or zaz
to it or something like that right yeah
it just feels like a little out of well
yeah I guess the weakness is some of the
the foreign policy stuff something like
that uh VC the strength obviously the
strength is off the cuff go into a
debate you're a sellout you're a liar
blah blah blah and I would also say
that's his weakness because there's a
way to do that really effectively and he
at times can do it incredibly
effectively and to open up that debate
basically saying to the moderator you
guys push the Russia collusion hoax like
do you think it was real yes or no it's
like really great and then a minute
later he insults everybody on the stage
and then says we shouldn't insult each
other he he's just trying to do a lot of
things at once and as and actually in
his defense as he would say he's only 38
years old so maybe he just has to work
on that a bit more uh next up Elizabeth
says does Clyde have a favorite between
the two
boys uh well Justin is way more into
pulling Clyde's ears and poking him at
all times and constantly chasing him
around the couch so my suspicion is that
he's a little more into Luke these days
who just lets him uh chill out but we
will see as time goes by but it's really
been nice to see that Clyde Clyde's big
and strong and everything else he has
very little aggression in him he's
definitely not an alpha dog um but
obviously a dog just could accidentally
when they're playing around could swipe
you or nibble at you or whatever and
he's just been absolutely absolutely
great with them and actually if one like
if I you know if I'm doing something for
a minute in the kitchen and Justin
wanders off into the dining room or
something and next thing I hear him
crying Clyde immediately runs over there
or sometimes he'll even run to me to
imply like go go do something about that
so it's been pretty great uh Mitchell
says other than the obvious the boys and
David what is Dave Ruben thankful for
this Thanksgiving season it will sound
corny but I am thankful for you guys
truly I wake up every day I am doing
what I'm supposed to do I feel like it's
relevant and important I think in the
last seven or so weeks in light of world
events I I've never felt better in terms
of what I am doing not necessarily the
content specifically because obviously
it can be really tough and emotionally
draining and especially those first few
weeks you know when we were covering
some of the awful stuff around kidnap
babies and all that stuff and the boys
were sick with covid so I'm in here
talking about that stuff and then I'm
sleeping on the floor with Luke as he's
coughing up and that's all crazy but I I
get to do what I want to do with great
people and uh and my day is never the
day never ends and I'm like H you know I
didn't want to do that you know some
days the show is awesome and we knock it
out of the park and we all know it every
now and again it's not and we know that
to but like the the the general
direction of everything we're doing I
think is very much in line with
something I would have dreamed about a
long time ago and so the point is I'm
appreciative for you guys who tune in
and allow us to do this and especially
those of you who support us on locals
and keep us independent so I can just
say what I think and we see what happens
Kelly says is there a holiday tradition
that you grew up doing with your family
that you want to make sure to continue
with the boys and hopefully they'll
continue with their families yes many
many families do this so this definitely
wasn't born out of my family but
especially on Thanksgiving but you
should try this on other holidays as
well like what are you thankful for go
around the table and everybody say
something and it's not easy for
everybody and it can be emotional
sometimes somebody sometimes somebody's
sick somebody just lost a family member
or the whole family just lost somebody
or somebody's out of work or all the
covid craziness whatever it might be but
taking one minute to think like what am
I actually thankful for this year and I
have an awful lot to be thankful for
this year so we we will definitely be
doing that tomorrow uh Joe says what's
the plan for the turkey this year I will
be getting to it in a couple hours I
have a 17 pound regenerative Le farmed
turkey you can Google whatever the hell
that means it was very expensive uh and
I'm doing all sorts of of herbs and I'm
going to do a really nice rub all over
that thing and then I'm throwing it in
the Big Green Egg 17 lbs I think it's
going to be about 10 hours maybe even
more 12 hours I got a lot of work to do
but I'll post some pictures in locals
community and then we're very blessed
David's family's here they're great
chefs we're going to have a beautiful
beautiful meal as I hope you guys will
as well uh Rachel says I'd like to know
about your sense of style I love how you
dress and that you appreciate the formal
look and I'm wondering if you've always
been like that uh also as a teenager and
younger person or did this come at a
certain point uh well first off uh this
today's clothing uh this is a Zara
jacket probably cost $60 I don't want to
brag and uh this shirt I got this at
Nordstrom but I think it was a bit of a
pricier shirt um but I do think to do a
show like this that I should dress a
certain way you know it's interesting
because when we were in London and we
did a couple shows out there I was
wearing the full suit and I uh you know
had the tie on and everything and and
the dress shoes and all that and I there
is a professionalism that comes with
that so for me when I do this show this
is a little more casual obviously if I'm
not wearing a tie and I am wearing jeans
right now yes I'm wearing pants um but
if I'm going to communicate the day's
news to you in in a somewhat and I do it
obviously in a silly way when I'm most
happy in doing it the way I want to do
it but I can't I can't always be silly
um but we're talking about some serious
stuff so I should basically look the
part um you know I there are plenty of
other guys that do these types of shows
that are doing it in t-shirts and
everything and teach his own all that um
I would say in the last couple years my
style has definitely got better in the
last well Phoenix's fiance has has upped
the level of the style and change my
hairstyle a little bit and some other
things um I would
say clothing wise well another piece
would be Jordan right like part of the
stand up straight with your shoulders
back and pres how do you want to present
yourself to the world um and actually I
wrote about this in the last book like
even even these days like if I go
out just to go to the grocery store or
whatever like I know that people know
who I am so like I try not to just show
up in a ratty shirt not that I can't be
seen in a ratty shirt but you try to
just put your put your best self out
there it's like on airplanes that's the
one when it always hits me like I always
try to dress decently especially for for
a flight not necessarily because I'm
going to be recognized but when you see
all these people get on planes they got
dirty ass sweatpants and they're wearing
their Crocs which is just the worst on a
plane and you know headphones blasting
and like you know and just sloppy gross
and you're like like what are you saying
to the world and then you look back at
what people were wearing on airplanes in
the 1960s and everyone's in a nice suit
looks good or how they used to go to the
theater and that's very different now or
all that like I think if you just dress
up if you dress the part you might start
living the part how about that guys I
want to thank you for watching I am
thankful for you there is no postgame
show today because I'm letting these
fine people you you're all going to
leave you're going to leave me now and
go with your families eat turkey and
other stuff okay fine uh but I do thank
you all for watching I am thankful for
you so no postgame show of course we are
off for Thanksgiving and Friday so we
will be back on Monday and are we
leaving them with this cold close it's
sort of is irrelevant largely
but oh man America what are you going to
do and the Eagles are so much better
than the
[Applause]
Eagles